red wine white wine Rosie this is the
Doritos locos taco from Taco Bell what
would i pair with this champagne LaSalle
it's a vintage 2006 means it's really
good when do you ever pair these two
together I think it was genius - stuck
in the cardboard we move we proofread
fruit wow the saltiness makes the
champagne tastes a little sweeter it
doesn't taste like those two things
should be in my mouth it does help wash
it down then champagne is like clean
this is the Big Mac by McDonald's two
all-beef patties special sauce lettuce
cheese pickles onions on a sesame-seed
bun when you're pairing wine with food
you always pair with the sauce so french
rose' from Provence south of France is
Chateau leo it's not any rosy it's a
super rosy the sauce is so it's like
buttery and rich and this wine
complements it nicely I've never felt so
[ __ ] classy I feel like this is like
Rick Ross's diet every day it's really
refreshing oh how delightful fifty bucks
for this wine damn Netflix wine
McDonald's and chill I'm sweating my
supposed to be sweating how do you are
this is the classic cheese pizza by
Domino's what would you pair with cheese
pizza bhadiya accion oh this Chianti
Classico is vintage 2010 which was an
exceptional vintage it tastes like fruit
roll-ups oh gear a little more bitter
redder mmm she is yummy soft thought he
was about to dip that in there oh no you
shouldn't Psalms in fast-food
restaurants
this is gonna be a thing in the future I
made a huge biscuit
it makes the food feel even more
expensive I will never eat pizza the
same again I don't like the crust I'll
eat your crust any day now a full bodied
pizza full-bodied wine it's too much
body over here you're gonna buy a wine
to go with fast food this is the one
like it's a perfect match it was a fun
way to class up our fast food Pizza and
the red wine was greatly champagne with
taco was brilliant
my favorite was McDonald's and Rosie
like a little but the thought is my
mouth oh it's still there job oh okay
[Music]